Hey guys, welcome to odd man out. K-pop super fans.
But before we get into the video,
I just wanted to tell you that you're at Jubilee are trying to get to know you
the community so we can brainstorm ideas and come up with some cool stuff that
you actually care about for 2021.
So make sure you click on the link below and fill out the anonymous survey.
Now let's get into the episode.
K-pop K-pop 90 million K-pop fans worldwide.
[inaudible]
we truly have the best fans we brought together.
Seven K-pop super fans.
I'm a K-pop super fan. I'm a K-pop super fan. K-pop super fan.
I'm a K pop super fan. I'm a K-pop super fan. I'm a K-pop super fan.
I am a K-pop super fan.
One is a liar. If the group discovers who the liar is, they'll win a cash prize.
If the liar survives, they win the cash prize.
This is odd and out.
The mall is either a fan of like one group, but not K-pop as a whole,
or they live with a K-pop super fan.
I'm just going to try and be myself using that.
Can you ask the most basic questions? Like what group are you into?
If someone were to say BTS or black pink,
I'm going to be SaaS. All right.
All these people who just found out about BTS.
There since the beginning, I'm actually so nervous.
Like if you can see my hands, I'm literally sweating right now.
I know my stuff, but at the same time,
I feel like I'm going to blank because I don't know anything.
I don't know dates. I don't know the name of your dog.
I I'm not going to make it.
What's everyone's old.
So my favorite group is black. So I got my favorite group is.
I really like black PCs.
Yeah. I love black paint. Their new album. Oh my God.
Yeah. So good. Not a bad track on the new album miles card though. Hidden cards.
My current favorite group is BTS. My favorite group absolutely is 21.
Oh God. Yes. Yes. Sales come back.
What got everyone into K-pop big bags. It's a big thing.
Orange, caramel, orange caramel.
[inaudible] I love orange Kamal. Nano is like my first celebrity.
My daughter is in a dance crew. So that's how I, that's how I got into K-pop.
Oh, that's so cool that your daughter. Oh, I got it.
Kind of a sad way. I used to not have a lot of friends.
So on the tray home from high school, I listened to shiny.
I got into K-pop with my best friend.
She had actually moved from South Korea and was like, look at what we got.
And I was like, okay. Yeah. But I really fell into it with shiny with replay.
I was obsessed.
I was supposed to see BTS coming in Chicago from Apple soul. Oh.
Wait, are you from Chicago?
I'm from Minnesota. But I was going to drive to Chicago for the days.
I was supposed to see monster X, but the shutdown was a week before it started.
It was her worst. I was so.
Oh, Brown was just very hectic.
Everybody had such good answers and I thought it was going to be obvious.
I dunno. I feel like some of these, these guys are like, Oh, G K-pop fan.
And I'm not because I only got into K-pop a few years ago,
Amy Marni. I'm just going to go. I'm just going to vote for it. Send us.
I'm really sorry. How may I feel like he didn't really have enough time.
I'm going to vote for a Troy? I don't know.
I just seems like he was a little bit nervous. Right?
She said her daughter is a K-pop fan.
Everything she's learned could be from her daughter.
I feel like that could just be her daughter.
Everything seems so picture perfect and set up with like the frames.
And I feel like a fake fan would like do that much.
I think I'm just going to have to pick Andrew because for no reason, other than,
I don't know anyone to pick him, my ex-husband's name was Andrew.
The votes are in for round one.
And the person that eliminated this round is Frankie.
I can't believe this. I'm actually a bit up. I'm upset about being eliminated.
It couldn't be because I was really enjoying this.
I think I'm eliminated because I'm an older fan. Is she eliminated?
I'm in a blank wall and they eliminated her and all her K-pop March.
There was no hope.
You will have 10 minutes to search and gather your most prized K-pop related
merchandise.
Okay? Okay. I get it. My stuff, God. So much rummaging.
Okay. There it goes. The boa shiny album, monster X two pants. XO.
I made t-shirts for super end because I hated the ones that SM in Capitol
records made. It's literally only BTS March though. I'm going to get flamed.
People have constantly pointed out, like, do you own socks? That aren't K-pop.
Oh, Y if you understand my reference,
your actual true K-pop superfan is my door,
my desk drawer.
I already had a bunch of my stuff up and ready for us.
I got this album and this is my bias.
This is my K-pop box. It's really bad. Normally this is locked.
So here is my sign stack CD like, Hey, Khan, he's billboards.
Here's the love of my life. Tiffany Young, 70 young Kwan.
I went to the Vancouver show. I went to
Tiffany.
Here's the thing I support K-pop through iTunes nowadays.
So I'm going to print out what I have on my iTunes.
Not all of us can afford.
Okay. Hey guys. So this is my bow at 20th anniversary, large Soju glass.
I love all my life.
This is my super empty shirt that I had made 21 all my life crushed.
You know what already?
She's an original fan to PM groan. And then lastly,
my NCT one to seven Apple music event. T-shirt I don't know how I got in,
but God saw me. He said, you're going.
And so I went and I saw them and I got this t-shirt at the end.
This is actually a convention it's called K-pop North.
And I was actually a volunteer for it.
So I got to meet a bunch of different people.
So volunteered at KACO new door. It was so much fun.
Every single ICU album, every single black.
Oh, this man has takes. Hold on. I'm never going to doubt him in my life.
The wallet,
I literally have my up and my dad actually thought this was my girlfriend.
And I had to tell him it wasn't so going to buy that.
My first item is ran on the wind by card.
I stand far loving to come watch.
I don't have a lot of merchandise because I am a broke college student.
I'm broke. I am going to show you guys.
I support through iTunes like Luna. Didn't go.
Number one for nothing. So I printed like my purchase list.
I don't know,
But there's the black PNC I'll dream catcher.
That is dedication. Thank you. [inaudible] yes.
Yes. So I have.
To sign the albums from GCU and Jenny. So jealous.
I've never seen signed black pink albums. I've no idea how she got that.
I had this VT tell one it's shimmy. I love that.
And then I have so many albums.
I'm conflicted with Sundays. She has items,
but they're very mainstream black teen BTS.
Okay. I'll try and go fast. Um,
I have every like limited edition BTS members on Joe board for the
cover. I have every single one.
I went to 16 different Barnes and Nobles to get it.
Absolutely.
We stand Barnes and Nobles. K-pop heaven.
Oh, wait, am I a fan of it?
Three signed months to X albums.
I've been wearing it since the beginning.
It's one of my most precious things it has BTS is debut day Shirky and
tiny shucky, big socks and BTS socks. It will piggy back.
She who is my bias in BTS.
I bet you can't tell on a bunch of BTS albums from all BTS stuff.
So I'm thinking she's just a BTS fan at night. K-pop super fan.
Seeing people's merchandise definitely helped me seeing people's merchandise to
not help at all.
I'm going to vote for Dara.
I think it's just like the fact that her only albums are just from a long time
ago. I feel like she might not be a current fan of K-pop.
I'm going to vote for Andrew because I think the most obvious one
maybe sometimes could be the most,
I guess I'm just going to vote for Ava this time.
Just because all of her was BTS, but she did have the big socks.
Does. She has a lot of mainstream merchants.
I feel like she had two things that were great, but that was it.
Wait, no, I'm not going to vote for her. I like her too much.
I guess I'd vote for me again. I feel bad.
We have counted all the votes and the person that eliminated this round is
send us cinder.
Good. This sucks.
This is very difficult. And I'm so sorry guys.
But the only music video I can think of right now is afterschool bang.
I literally watch this every.
Day, Bob, first of.
All, afterschool very talented group. They learned things for the music videos.
They did the tap dancing. They did the drums. They did the pole dancing.
They had that iconic hip part where they turned, they hit the hips swing, swing,
swing. [inaudible].
What came to mind of course is by cards and gunshot their newest release.
It's actually a really big music video.
And it means a lot because this is the last video of them. Four before JSF, uh,
enlist in the military.
They each write about how online words in bullying her idols and
how toxic the fan base can actually be. Hit me like a gun.
Boom, boom.
[Inaudible].
No, I'm going to talk about Luna. Mine is UBS new.
So how it works is they all debuted as singular members.
They reverse engineered how, uh, groups are made.
The whole song is about accepting yourself and being true to yourself.
And there's also a lot of bisexual coding and it was this moment where I
realized Luna was so important. And how,
how important K-pop is in general because K-pop has pushed so many boundaries
and move so many people forward towards really fast.
I agree. I don't think CAPOX a leader is sexuality though. I disagree with that.
Okay.
He has a company are so strict.
It is a rebellious act for a K-pop Fido to go on stage and say,
I support LGBTQ and they hold up rainbow.
So I think my favorite changes literally every year, of course, right now,
it's not shy by it. See, it doesn't have the deepest story,
but I think it's a really fun video. I'm a film major.
So I think people don't really appreciate how hard it is to shoot some of these
videos. They have these insane cut shots. I learned the whole dance.
Like not shy until thing like I can watch when I'm feeling down,
when I'm feeling happy, it like really cheers me up. But yeah.
Okay. She, she knows she's a fan. I'm not sophisticated.
Afterschool sub unit orange caramel.
I'm specifically talking about the Cadillac and music video.
What I love about it is that they kind of push the boundaries.
They literally dress as sushi. They're literally swimming in soy sauce.
They incorporate comedy into their music videos,
which is not something a lot of members do.
It was like, he knows it. I don't know. Truly, truly.
I find it hard to believe that any of these people are the malls.
I think I'm going to go with Andrew again. Everyone had like a unique group.
And then he said, what Darren had.
I'm definitely most suspicious of Ava. Now, you know,
she only talked about BTS and then she just mentioned Etsy.
She's only talking about the main level group.
Sorry, Andrew much love. I think you're the moment actually. I think I'm going,
if you don't mind.
I'm sorry, Tara. I love you, Tara. I literally love you.
I just feel like Darren just isn't into K-pop as much as she.
I'm not sure. I think I'm going to vote for Troy just to mix it up.
And the person eliminated this round is Andrew.
I knew it
was going bye-bye.
And the question is, do you guys want to continue the game?
If everyone feels confident that you already caught them all,
you can end the game now, but if majority has doubt,
the game will continue.
I don't know. I don't know.
I don't suspect these people, but I feel like four is like a high number.
You know, guys, I'm exhausted.
What should we do, guys? What do you guys think at home?
I have still suspicious of Daraa.
There's one more question. I just kind of want to get out there.
So I feel like being a K-pop super fan,
like is also recognizing that there are many things wrong in the K-pop industry.
For example, the suicide.
I was a huge fan of shiny and I was a really big fan of AOA.
So hearing about the bullying between GMN and Nino was really hard to
hear.
And I was wondering if there's any sides you guys have seen that like you were
willing to work to change within the K-pop.
I think that SaaS things like are super toxic to be so obsessive and not let
them have their freedom.
The like really crazy like stock green.
It's just crazy to me. And also I'm not an anti fan. I don't like that.
I'm not going to go on VTS age or someone pays you just click this slide. Yeah.
One thing in particular, um,
I'm really big on like cultural appropriation saying
certain wards and things. Like, I really fight about these things. Um,
just because I feel like, you know what you're doing, you just don't care.
And that to me says that you don't want me to be your fan.
The members from secret code.
I believe she posted black lives matter on her Instagram and her company like
took it down. Did you guys hear about that secret number?
That's messed up. I do have a really good question for you guys.
Who do you think is responsible for the blowup of K-pop like I know some people
say VTS. I know some people say boa girls' generation.
Okay. I will say boa.
I remember her dropping did it for love. And I was like, now
what? Like I just blown away.
I feel like BTS got to where they are because these other groups kind of opened
in a way I'm not suspicious of anyone.
I'm probably going to vote for him. Jaime. I knew.
A lot. He really understands K-pop Dar is good.
Like there's no doubt in my mind that Dar is not a super fan.
I've known since frickin round table.
So I'm going to have to vote for Ava this round.
Okay. We shouldn't have done another round. I'm so sorry. Dari. Like,
I feel so bad voting for you.
Guys. We made a mistake. We're all K-pop stands. This is no,
I don't know why we continued on forgive us. I will vote for,
um.
My heart is pounding. You guys I'm so nervous.
And the person that eliminated this round is Ava.
Yeah.
We have three people left. Are we going to round five or not?
No.
We definitely caught them all. I'm.
Very competent in this final three weeks.
I feel you, Troy. I know you.
So if the color that shows up behind me is green. You all win. If it's red,
the mole is still in the game and you will.
I'm looking at Jaime right now and you don't mad suspicious right now.
Oh, Martin.
It's not dark. It has to. Behind me.
I knew it was dark.
Oh,
I know exactly who the mole is. I know it's hi mate.
The game is over and the K-pop super fans have lost.
That means the mole has won and will be receiving a cash prize.
We're also going to be gifting them all the akin to experience where they will
get to pick their favorite basics from our new interactive apparel brand.
We'll the mole. Please raise your hand in three, two,
one.
Hi guys.
[Inaudible] I suspected everyone except you like
[inaudible].
I'm a music publicist. I've been in the industry for quite a years. Now.
I honestly only know the basics. I couldn't name a single member of BTS,
but I definitely respect you guys. You know,
working as a publicist K-pop would not be what it is today without its fans.
Like did you go to K con as like a publicist? No, I didn't.
Those were my friends, brothers slits that I got.
[Inaudible].
We literally voted out for super fans and kept them all.
Well,
I guess a true K-pop super fan is honestly someone that's just willing to have
some fun. Someone who loves music, it doesn't.
Trash other groups. We are all races, all genders, all ages,
and it's really much bigger than most people think. I think for so long,
we've lived in a world where we've treated music and mainstream music,
especially in Western markets is only an English thing.
K-pop has literally changed my life.
It's given me the excitement back to actually go out and do things.
You know,
I just used to be so insecure about my ethnicity and who I am as a Korean.
Uh,
seeing how popular K-pop has gotten over the 10 years and seeing how many people
are interested in K-pop that's made me proud to be South Korean. So for that,
I'm going to be always be grateful towards K-pop.
[Inaudible].
I hope you enjoyed that episode.
I had a blast directing it and meeting so many passionate K-pop fans.
If you're a K-pop fan,
make sure you comment below with who's your favorite K-pop artists or K-pop
group. And if you're not a K-pop fan,
you can leave some suggestions for future odd man out episodes. Don't forget.
Click on the link below and fill out the anonymous survey.
This will help us out to get to know you the community so we can brainstorm
cool ideas and cool stuff that you actually care about for 2021.
Thanks for watching hit that like button.
Make sure you share this video with family and friends and that's okay.